hey what's up Daniel Dwyer here with
more tips for overwatch Chris waters I
feel like Lucio is one of the characters
that people pick the least but he's also
one of the most effective the audio
medic as it were is capable of doing
quite a lot on the battlefield Chris
let's break it down tell me all about
Lucio Lucio is my man and I think the
reason some people shy away from him is
one of the most powerful things you can
do is Lucio is just be around your team
is passive ability which is to heal
anyone within line of sight is super
valuable for pushing payloads for
keeping teams alive for you know being
on points and really you just have to be
near people of course you can switch
from healing to the speed the speed is I
would say more of a situational thing
your default should be healing yeah all
the time is speed use probably mostly
the start of Maps right at the start of
maps when you respawn also once your
team is healed up you know you can give
them that little mid match sort of
juicing let's talk about healing because
this is still his most important thing
you are around people and you can see
how many people you're holding by
looking under the reticle it'll tell you
how many teammates you see the amp it up
ability which juices your healing and
kicks it up a notch is super good for
saving teammates and you want to keep an
eye on those silhouettes and those
critical health bars and overwatch is
great it's signaling to you how your
teammates health is doing you want to
respond to that as Lucia and it's
probably easier to use him in terms of
other heaters because he just kind of
heals everyone around and it's not like
you have to be so so worried about your
positioning and what about as old when
should you kick that in just whenever
comes around or in specific situation so
his alt throws down these huge shield
buffs for anyone again in eyesight and
it's great for countering a team push or
when you are trying to push in on
something it can also help you if fara
is rocketing down on you or there's an
or you're drawn into Zara's ultimate
trap it can help encountering high
damage burst damage Ultimates and keep
your team alive in those crucial
situations and so Lucio can get around
the map pretty easy he's got a wall ride
ability as well and when should you be
using that and also what positioning
should you be using for Lucia where
should keeping you in the fight the wall
ride I picture it as more of almost a
wall jump as being more valuable because
what you want to do is make yourself
hard to hit you take one shot from a
Widowmaker you stay in bastion sights
for two seconds you are done you've got
no you've got low
but if you're nimble if you're always
hopping around sort of doing little kick
flips off the wall and stuff that's
gonna help you stay alive and you want
to stay near your team because you are
also a damage dealer that needs to be
recognized yeah his default gun is
actually pretty good at like dealing a
nice steady amount of damage on to big
foes and on to smaller ones to chipping
away at tanks is very valuable you can
also if you pop in and out you sort of
edge a Torbjorn turret or a bastion that
can help but you're always always just
firing sending those bullets in towards
the enemy and then of course the
alternate buyer is a push-off which is
great for survivability
yeah when should you be using that
someone gets up in your face and you're
like well I don't need to be next to a
road hog right now you want to bounce
him with the alt fire of your gun
because it will push back of course
there's also a bunch of capture maps on
the assault mode that are real juicy for
bumping people off the ledge oh it's
beautiful
if you can score those you're gonna put
a smile on just make sure you're not up
against a character who's actually able
to get back up when you do that because
they're going to be pretty angry last
point on this matchups depress and avoid
Chris who should you be going after as
lucio we should be staying with well you
don't want to be close to anybody really
because anyone with a moderate amount of
damage is going to be able to beat you
in close quarters you know you could
chase down a diva outside of our suit or
a mercy if you get in that situation but
mostly you want to hang back a little
bit always be firing towards the enemy
and it's ok if you're taking fire from a
soldier 76 or any other sort of medium
damaged characters because you are
constantly healing yourself which makes
you actually surprising to the road so
if you want to be a cross-fading ask
reggae looking medic man you should pick
lucio and for more tips on all of the
overwatch characters sub here and stay
tuned sticking spawn
Oh